Once you know where you intend to
distribute your app, you can design for
localization.
Planning early is key as you need to
consider the space and locations for
each language.
You can reuse your default layout
if you build a flexible UI.
The key to this is to allow elements
to expand horizontally and vertically.
And also to leave about 30%
more space than you need for
your default language, so the
translations will have plenty of room.
If you need an alternative layout,
though, you can tag it with the relevant
qualifiers so that the resource
framer can find it automatically.
But, using the mini alternative
layouts will be harder to maintain.
So you'll need to determine
what's best for your app.